the relationship advice I just can't
help but hear myself oh man
you what I'm okay yeah you peed yourself
no I think be yourself all right what do
you got man we got Devin Hayley Devin
ailing Hayley from Raleigh North
Carolina okay let's see what this young
fellas into not him so fellas boy Devin
from Raleigh North Carolina here gang
brother need some relationship advice so
I've been talking to this girl for just
a little bit and she seems great great
personality I can hold a conversation
which is very nice you have a lot of
things in common but we just started
talking and basically she seems to be
very busy she's taking a lot of classes
for grad school as well as working a lot
and well the weekends as well sometimes
from 8:00 to 8:00 on Saturday and Sunday
that's a lot I get the busy schedule
because I'm I'm working myself as well
as taking classes so it's not easy but
I'm just wondering if having these
thoughts already so early in a stalking
stage is even worth considering dating
her at all so I just need some help from
you guys whether I should keep pursuing
or if I should just move on
love you guys love everything you do
slang gang bust up I was expecting seems
like real up upright citizen you know I
like this guy
this is a legit advice question here's
the thing I always need more details
when it comes to this dude to help them
out because how old is she because when
I was in college there's no class on
Saturday Sunday
so she 8 to 8 a member who I'm saying
that's tough to buy brother but a lot of
women these days you know they get they
you know this is a feminism time do you
got women going back to school women
doing you know log cutting you got women
doing their Navy SEALs officer yeah you
know but you know Steve you know making
cocaine and it's getting different dude
women are climbing up you'll see a woman
open your window somebody's climbing by
you know like Oh where's she going you
knows washing your window angry you
should be just dudes well yeah it was
just more risky now these women are
being more risk takers and it takes more
time out of their day
and so what I'm saying is that I just
say you say to her
hey babe you know you seem like a nice
cool lady let's um if you I'd like to
take you out if you're free you let me
know because you seem busy that's what
I'd say yeah I would say what window are
you open if you're working Monday
through Sunday I'm not buying a girl hey
no one's that busy no one's that busy
well let's ask camp because she's a
female and she went to USC I mean it
does seem a little weird cuz I don't
know anybody who has classes on Saturday
for that long unless you have something
very specific I used to have those days
on certain parts of my semester but
that's cuz I'm a theatre student and I
had to be there I don't know if she's
actually that busy well she might have a
learning disability on the same scope I
think that if she's actively trying to
make up not me Greta's make up for like
missed out gates then she clearly wants
to spend time with him
if you're that busy and you continuously
try to go see him then I think now you
might have the next freaking Kylie
Jenner on your hands she's gonna be a
billion years pretty soon she'll be
hustling to make that Bank yeah that's
him right up for the sunset make a bunch
of babies dude yeah so I need more facts
off on my solve this case he seemed like
a nice guy this guy real nice Patrick is
that his name post though does it look
like it Devon no looks like a brand yeah
it does yeah bright or non haulin or
none hell
hmm well good luck dude good luck dude
you can always come down to the zoo and
work with me we will find some animals
make some time for you you know I'll see
you buddy uh I want I want in on the zoo
now though dude I'll see you bye the
tigress miss Tigers boy one more jela
you can make him babysit that one eagle
we're gonna have them yeah let me just
take care of that massive eagle yeah
back up my broccolini get your life
together